hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
um
august 1st
oh my god where is the [ __ ] summer
going
i've barely had time to get a lobster
roll
have you had the lobster roll down at
marx
oh it's the [ __ ] die for
the only thing i don't like is the
[ __ ] line is so goddamn long i go
through half a pack of ciggies
waiting for it
by the time i get up there burned all my
taste buds so i can't taste the lobster
butter um
yeah it's august 1st who the [ __ ] knew i
don't i don't by the way i don't [ __ ]
with lobsters
can you tell i'm tired as [ __ ] i took a
[ __ ]
i don't know red-eye but not a red-eye
early morning flight
back i barely slept because there was a
bunch of comics in the plane
coming back
from montreal
um had a great time up there at the
montreal comedy festival before i get
into that let's talk about why i don't
[ __ ] with lobster because they boil them
alive
and then people
who aren't lobsters say that the
lobsters don't feel anything
rather than they don't have a voice to
be like
um could you turn down the heat a little
bit
i'm getting a little red in my lobster
ass or we
right they can't say anything
you know
there aren't many
fish that say anything
they're mammals then they kind of run
their yaps is it dolphin a mammal
because it's got a couple little [ __ ]
whiskers
you like that dude who can just
never grow a beard his whole [ __ ]
life
that's actually a good thing if you're
pretty hairless
usually means you keep it on top of your
head but those [ __ ] guys with the
hairy backs in gym class in like 8th
grade they [ __ ] look like a
substitute teacher by the time they're
19.
um yeah i don't [ __ ] with lobster if i i
still don't understand
you know i bet if i was to look right
now
if i was to be inquisitive
um i would i would look this up right
now
okay
humane
way
to
cook
lobster
all right which is kind of funny because
you imagine if lobsters ate us oh
believe me buddy if they could they
would
they could get those [ __ ] claws were
a little bit bigger they'd take a lot
more than just your finger
um
how do we do this here let's see here
lobster is best when killed immediately
before cooking
well [ __ ] let's get to it unless you
bought a frozen lobster
what you brought home from the market is
alive and kicking and that leaves the
task up to the cook
what is the most humane way to dispatch
of a lobster
well i i respect this article because it
says it did say kilt so they're not
trying to like sugar coat killed this is
just good writing because they already
said killed in the in the paragraph and
for some reason when you're writing
it's not good to repeat words like that
um you look for synonyms even though
when regular when people are just
talking they repeat the same words all
the time
like are you [ __ ] kidding me dude you
[ __ ] kidding me
you know a better writer would have said
dude are you [ __ ] kidding me
and then be like bro
kid
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me um while
plunging the live lobster into a pot of
boiling water will surely be fatal there
is some to debate as to whether it is
cruel
now who the [ __ ] in the world is like
it's not cruel
it's absolutely cruel it's whether or
not you give a [ __ ] that you're doing it
uh the lobster's thrashing tail often
makes
a knocking sound inside the pot
sometimes loosening the lid and that can
make the cook
or those nearby waiting for dinner a bit
uncomfortable
yeah i wish this thing getting boiled
alive wouldn't quit disrupting our meal
hey we're over here trying to eat the
appetizers could you [ __ ]
get boiled alive a little quieter
uh but does the lobster suffer the jury
is still out on this one but most chef
agrees that dispatching a lobster before
cooking
is the best approach
killing before cooking there are a few
ways to kill a lobster
oh jesus but there's only one way to get
it in the pot
uh by doing it before cooking you have
the option to boil bake steam or cook it
another way freeze the lobster by
placing it in the free oh my god's got
to freeze to death
what would you choose boil delay you got
to go freeze to death
you
with the cold
there's me some [ __ ] out there going
well actually if you boil to death it'd
be over quicker they're both agonizing
deaths
shut up
[ __ ]
death expert uh freeze the lobster by
placing it in the freezer for 30 to 60
minutes before putting it you can't just
[ __ ]
take a little club and hit them on the
head
there you go a quicker option
is to plunge a knife straight down into
the carapace
part of the exoskeleton on the lobster's
back paste the tip of the sharp chef's
knife behind the lobster's eyes right
below where the claws meet the body and
halfway to the first joint swiftly
plunge the knife
down through the head the legs will
continue to move a bit but the lobster
is in fact dead why is there so many
mysteries with these [ __ ] lobsters
about whether they're feeling [ __ ]
whether they're alive or dead
i'm getting to the point where i'm gonna
start blaming the victim you know maybe
if these lobsters knew how to
communicate a little better
they could avoid such a horrible death
um
anyway oh my god
so [ __ ] wiped out but
my kids are coming
back from uh
hanging out over some friends houses um
a friend's house they had a play date
today my wife's bringing her back
and they're gonna be back here in like a
little bit i haven't seen him in two
days so i don't want to do anything else
other than play with them today
so
i am knocking this
the [ __ ] out
um
yes i was up in montreal i played the
bell center
where they hated haves
the abidance
play um
it was [ __ ] incredible uh what an
amazing crowd
they were uh just great sense of humor
and they just really listened
oh
you could take them on a ride i had an
absolute [ __ ] blast
and uh we showed the movie trailer for
old dads
everybody seemed to really enjoy that
and um
i'm getting uh
very excited about
whenever that movie comes out
and uh i worked with uh nate craig and
joe bartnick they both absolutely killed
thank you to bruce hills and everybody
at the montreal comedy festival
um i had i had a great time although i
was a little depressed
just thinking about how long i'd been
going to that thing i don't just
something
got me
you know i just think i spent a little
bit too much time alone in the hotel
room
the smoke started catching up with me
and i just started thinking about man
i remember when i first came here
because you know it's like [ __ ] had
changed and stuff you know i still did
the hike up the stairs
in that [ __ ] uh that beautiful park
they have
i always take a picture of the montreal
expo stadium olympic stadium
well
well covered which if i'm not mistaken i
think bruce jenner before he became
caitlyn won the decathlon there
wouldn't that be amazing if caitlyn
jenner came back
and you know
did the decathlon and then won
and then could be the first person to
ever win the mail
and female
decathlon and when is that going to
happen again
what i mean again it never happened but
if it did happen
um
you know if bruce didn't waste all that
time on chips instead of go doing chips
if you just became caitlyn
and did a couple episodes of cagney and
lacy you know he could have won them
both
it's got to haunt him for her
oh by the way rest in peace uh bill
russell
the great bill russell
has passed away um
just one of the most
important figures maybe in sports
history
right up there with uh
ali jackie robinson and everybody else
of that era
um
i think it's amazing that he lived to be
88 at his height you know how many like
six foot nine six foot ten
old guys do you see walking around and
you do you know why that is
it's because everybody gets the same
size hot
so it has to work that much harder to
pump the blood
to the tip of your toes and come back
again which is why even putting on a few
pounds
you know puts all this pressure on your
heart
um
i don't know why i would go into that
but i mean just like you know there's
been so many big men over the years that
die
prematurely like wilt chamberlain i
thought i don't know if he made 60.
um moses malone was another one daryl
dawkins all these big men that i you
know either just missed or watched their
careers have gone on to pass and bill
russell continued
to live live to be 88 so that's um
that is amazing but um one of the great
greats of all time
and um
yeah that [ __ ] blows but i mean it's
88
it's a weird thing when you live a long
life
yeah there's nobody left
but there's actually a lot of celtic
stuff that's kind of like the depression
that i had when i was up in montreal
you know when i wasn't around anybody i
was kind of going around the [ __ ] sea
and like
just all the [ __ ] memories i had and
how much time has gone by and how many
people i hung out with that are no
longer here anymore it's just [ __ ]
wild
yeah a couple people have lost their
minds
a couple people are dead than other
people you know like me got married had
kids and you just don't have time to
[ __ ] hang out and i'm just like what
the [ __ ]
i was like i gotta [ __ ] get out of
here i gotta go do the stairs i got to
keep going
you know it's really crazy
um
but if you're into that sort of morose
sort of if you're feeling that you want
to watch it if you want to if you're if
you're a little down in the dumps right
now and maybe you just want to hang
there for a little longer and you need a
movie that will uh
be a nice company for you
on the criterion channel
you know that has all the best [ __ ] um
there's no way to bring up that you
watch that channel without coming off
like a snob
um
i watched this movie that i'd never
heard of called uh fat city
uh starring stacy keach um
i have my [ __ ] brain i can't think of
anybody uh
and uh
jeff bridges
um
and then the woman and it got nominated
for an oscar i should just pull this up
right now it's a boxing movie
uh beautifully shot
um
let me see here
fat city
cast
there we go susan uh
susan terrell
um
nicholas
colosanto is that how you say his name
actually played coach on cheers
uh was in raging bull and all of that
just a [ __ ] incredible movie
um
i checked that out so
i watched a lot of [ __ ]
when i was in montreal i usually go to
like the young
comic showcase
um i wasn't able to get to it because my
flight got so delayed and i was only
there for like 36 hours so i went over
to this place called the nest had a
great time ran into tommy tiernon oh
tommy tierra
i had i didn't even know he was gonna be
there and i had just in the brief time
that i saw him
uh had a lot of laughs
just such a great guy one of the great
comics
in the world i got to see him do a
hilarious set
um and i didn't even realize that as i
was leaving that
the place where that comedy club
is
uh
was where the original
uh montreal forum was where rocket
richard and all of those guys played not
the one in the middle that i associate
with uh
gee cabinet chris chellios chris nylon
who else patrick wah
spoboda stefan richey
oh my god
it's funny now i look back like fondly
at all those memories and everything but
when we were playing those i [ __ ]
hated all of those guys
and now i'm like uh
i don't know
i think that's being in your 50s
you think back going like how cool is
that i screw the boston garden i
remember getting one time i got tickets
running the glass and [ __ ]
just was right there and you know
all of those guys that i [ __ ] hated
and i watched them on
wsvk tv 38
before nesting came around
fred cusick and uh who's this oh my god
what the [ __ ] was this
before derek sanderson
was it johnny pearson
i'll tell you right now fred all you
youngsters out there watch this ricky
middleton
he's gonna do it all himself on this one
over the blue line he's doing the whole
thing right now back in the night
fraser's the goalie right here oh
pearson's pointers in between periods
it was just it was the greatest was the
[ __ ] greatest so um
it was really uh
i don't know i hate to say this as a
bruins fan but this even in the new
place there's still that mystique of all
of those championships and the only
thing that sucks is they rolled up the
banners
which i actually kind of respected like
we're not gonna hang the banners while
somebody's in here telling [ __ ] jokes
but uh we had a great time and you know
bartnik [ __ ] hosts the puck off
podcast he's a hockey maniac nate craig
is also also a great hockey player
so we were all geeking out that we were
in there and we just had a
[ __ ] great time man it was awesome i
was do uh trying out my french
got to do it twice this month i was in
france last month i'm in montreal
i was actually noticing their accent a
little bit i was picking up so much [ __ ]
i got to what the [ __ ] did i say when i
was up there
uh
on plus si tu tua
and she was like man wait maybe we mean
can we can we speak familiar as opposed
to using vu we can use two
and uh i was able although i did [ __ ] up
i need i forgot to buy a belt
and i went to this [ __ ]
haberdashery store
and they just go bonjour hello
and i was like
i said no not citroen i go a belt
and these i forget i always forget about
centrion or something like that
i said i just said i want to buy a lemon
right and he laughed he said yeah that's
what you said
whatever baby steps you know lead to
bigger steps and then you're going
so um
i ended up having just such a [ __ ]
great time when i was up there
and um
i couldn't get to sleep because of
always i went to uh stogies
shout out to them uh rumor has it that
they're gonna be opening a comedy club
above the cigar bar
uh excited about that and uh but i
smoked two cigars so i came home i was
just kind of wired from the tobacco and
i couldn't go to sleep
and uh which ended up being a good thing
because
there's this drummer that i keep seeing
and uh i finally you know i saw one time
and she blew me away and i you know
i accidentally swiped and then you know
i had to go back into [ __ ] instagram
and within three seconds the video i was
watching was like 30 000 videos away and
i couldn't find it
um i hope i say her name right her name
is uh sarah thauer
um
and
she like just she has this video i i
gotta post it where she's just basically
giving like a drum lesson
and um
the [ __ ] is that noise
could tell that was human or a [ __ ]
animal
um
anyway uh
indian drummer i believe
and she came up playing the tabla
and the way they teach drums over there
is you have to sing the rhythms
rather than um
you know counting it how they teach it
here in the west
and uh
she just was singing these toddler
things these toddler rhythms i don't
know anything about it but it was just
fascinating
in like seven
and just her phrasing she's like i don't
i'm not gonna be able to do it justin
but there was so many things that she
was doing on the drums
that you actually do as a comedian or an
actor
and one she's like i don't want to be
thinking anything and i just was like
that's what the [ __ ] i think
is there somebody breaking into my
[ __ ] house what's going on here
oh the kids are home no are they
no
jesus christ i'm [ __ ] losing my mind
looking at my car in the driveway
i just see a car and i think somebody
came home
um
something happened
something got opened here uh who knows i
got bad
i get a bat and i get some [ __ ]
non-lethal weapons here
like my voice
please don't steal anything anyway she
was saying um
how she just wants her head to be clear
that's how i like think before i go and
go do a set like i don't want to be
thinking anything i don't be thinking
about what i'm open about i don't really
think about [ __ ] anything
just go out there
and just sort of lock in with the crowd
and then just see what happens
and uh she was doing you know
but as much as that's cool to do that as
a comedian at the end of the day i'm
still talking which is what
i had been doing for 23 years before i
became a comedian so what amazes me
about musicians is they have to learn
how to talk all over again
through their instrument and she is just
an absolute
juggernaut on the drums and one of the
freest people i've ever seen in my life
anyway uh she just doesn't give a [ __ ]
and i really feel like the uh support
she got as a kid
because i was a half hour video and i
was like
as blown away
by her drumming as i was as her as a
person
like how just free she was
and confident and all that i just
absolutely loved her playing i went down
this rabbit hole and saw that she played
with sheila e and all of these people
whatever and then it also got me like
trying to learn some of those tabla
chants or songs rhythms whatever they're
called and i came across uh
this video
of um this guy zakir hussein i know i'm
pronouncing all these wrong he played
with like george harrison back in the
day he's one of the great great
greatest of all time but him and this
other guy i'm going to say the name
wrong
uh so anybody who's into this type of
music please send it phonetically and
i'll say it right next week uh rakesh
i don't know how to say his name but he
plays like
their version of the flute
i watched this [ __ ] it was absolutely
hypnotic they both sit down on the floor
rakesh guy starts playing zakir is
sitting there for like 10 minutes
doesn't do anything
and this guy is just
mesmerizing
and creates this vibe and then all of a
sudden the secure guy slowly starts
incorporating
you know
his tablet rhythms and everything and i
was just like
oh holy [ __ ] i never even knew
like you know what it was it was that
sarah
power thing that i watched that gave me
access and to be able to begin to
understand
how incredible the music from india is
which i already knew it was but it was
just always like you know it's just
something that's just so different from
what you're listening to it's like hard
to listen to because you can't
keep up with like a new language you're
like how the [ __ ] am i gonna learn all
of that right
so um
i'll post the video you got you gotta
[ __ ] watch it it's just
insane if you play any instrument
whatsoever
and uh
i can't even tell you how satisfying
everything i just told you was to to
to watch so um and thank god for whoever
posted those videos and for sarah making
those great videos
uh because i was going into a [ __ ]
depression
up in montreal and it totally pulled me
out of it and i was up till five in the
morning just watching all of this stuff
just
just blew my [ __ ] mind absolutely
blew my mind
um
i think i [ __ ] my shoulder up again
you know [ __ ] idiot but i don't think
i did it that bad
i think i can recover it's like i'm
going all the way back but i definitely
a couple of steps back i pushed it a
little bit um
uh [ __ ] stupid
goddamn impatient [ __ ] bald ginger
son of a [ __ ]
um
red sox are being the red sox just a
tough year with the injuries i'm sick of
[ __ ] people [ __ ] on the red sox
too like the level of injuries that we
have this [ __ ] year we we literally
half the time half our team out there
should be playing in worcester so
[ __ ] off with that
uh one of my yankee
fan friends was giving me [ __ ]
or whatever just show me how good aaron
judges do it
and uh you know
i mentioned to him that the dodgers now
have the best record
in in baseball
did the new york yankees peak too soon
it's probably better now that if you're
a yankee fan it's better now that this
[ __ ] [ __ ] the bed in in july
they got plenty of time to get momentum
going again so they can maybe uh
you know get something going in october
but i just [ __ ] i'm just telling you
like i [ __ ] hate yankee fans and i
hate laker fans because they both had
the same thing in common no matter how
many [ __ ]
free agents they have on their team they
can't have enough and if anybody
becomes available
you know
they they want to add them to their 900
zillion dollar team and it's just like i
don't understand what yankee fans and
laker fans have against competition it's
like they don't even want to see
competition they want to see all the
stars in the league on their team and
then they win by 100 runs or 100 points
every night and they're like yeah this
is this is enjoyable to watch
um
but
i think that that's a symptom of
um
just everybody plays that fantasy
football fantasy baseball so like they
all fancy themselves like general
managers anyway
so they they i don't know and they're
always [ __ ] picking up different
players on the whatever this little
fantasy thing that they're they're in
sports
that's this is the funniest i've never
played that [ __ ] i'm sure it's fun but
i'm just like
i don't you know i was talking to
bartnik about this it's like
did you ever give a [ __ ]
when you were growing up watching sports
who was making what
did you ever give a [ __ ] what they were
doing off the field
you only gave a [ __ ] about the game the
[ __ ] game came on there was five
minutes of pre-game five minutes of post
game and you watched the [ __ ] game
that was
it i didn't need you know i guess
they're sports writers some of them
would like gossip a little bit
um
i mean you have to be doing [ __ ] at the
level of like derek sanderson or like
joe namath back in the day for people to
actually be talking about what you were
doing off the field but other than that
no one knew what you're doing and nobody
gave a [ __ ]
um all right with that let me read uh
let me read a little bit of the uh the
advertising here if i could find it
just realized i forgot to uh
to look it up here
oh by the way the name of that video too
is sarah though
s-a-r-a-h-t-h-a-w-e-r
master class on her youtube channel
and beyond her playing just how free she
is
as a person and how much in the
the best way possible she doesn't give a
[ __ ]
i loved it um
all right oh here we go
let me see here oh live reads
oh look who it is solo stove i love this
thing
just pop up a little
fire pit anywhere you want to go it's
got the nice
silver chrome look to it you know it's
clean looking all right solo stoves
life's best moments happen around a
roaring fire
um
and a smokeless fire pit from solo stove
makes your outdoor moments even more
memorable
uh there's nothing like a roaring fire
to bring you back to what matters yeah
is there enough water close by there's
something about a roaring fire it just
makes it not sound like it's under
control
you know
where the flames are so big you have to
shout over them
sucking up all that [ __ ] oxygen
the flames are so big they're actually
absorbing sound
oh no
um
ah [ __ ]
is it does it ever end does it ever
[ __ ] end
i gotta hit pause here because i gotta
go look at some [ __ ] let me finish
reading this thing
um
i said oh no cause somebody was calling
me i forgot that i have to do this
[ __ ] edit thing
um there's nothing like a roaring fire
to bring you back to what matters yeah
not not burning to death uh the things
digital
the things digital distractions
and the frenzy of everyday life
make too easy to forget upgrade your
backyard with the solo stove fire pit
that's a [ __ ] window that keeps
blowing open or the slowest serial
killer ever
uh upgrade your backyard with the solo
stove fire pit and create story worthy
moments without the fireside fumes
stainless steel construction designed to
regulate airflow and burn more
efficiently so little smoke you'll
wonder how there's so much fire
easy to light with a few bits of starter
your fire is blazing in minutes they're
so confident you'll love it they offer a
lifetime warranty and a 30-day free
return policy right now you can get big
discounts on all the fire pits during
solo stove summer sale and use promo
code burr b-u-r-r at solostove.com for
an extra ten dollars off at
solostove.com promo code burr for ten
dollars off of their incredible summer
sale discounts all right i gotta hit
pause here people because i gotta look
at these [ __ ] scenes that we're
editing and then i'll be right back
all right and i'm back
um all right let's continue with the
reads and no cheeto
uh you know whether you're going to be a
groom in a wedding party
oh whether you're going to be a groom
comma in a wedding party i'm like where
else the [ __ ] you're going to be a groom
or a lucky guest everyone wants to look
their best for a wedding with a custom
fitted suit from indochito
you'll look great feel confident enjoy
the big day without fussing over your
clothes you might even get out of a
ticket
choose every detail on a suit shirt and
dinner jacket
dinner jacket who wears a dinner jacket
this is my jacket to eight
roy i'm gonna have a little rhino
and more at affordable prices that may
surprise you
for fully customized pieces every suit
is made to your exact measurements and
you can customize every
last
[ __ ] detail create a suit that fits
you and your style perfectly with
options for fabrics lapel shape
custom monograms statement linings and
more i saw somebody wearing this at a
wedding i was like my god that's a
beautiful super blah blah i thought it
was you know
thought he spent some money
didn't cost him nothing
it cost him like 125 the best part
indochido's suit stuff from just 429 and
shirts from 79 indochino offers also
offers completely custom fitted shirts
casual and more get a wardrobe
personalized to your style and taste
without spending a fortune they're
always adding new pieces and options so
you can stay on trend in style explore
they're relaxed yet refined
approach to spring suits with their new
spring pastels
it's [ __ ] august
if you've got a big day it must be
global warming spring stretching out if
you got a big day coming up getting the
perfect look is no big deal within no
cheeto get 50 off eddie purchase the 399
or more by using the code bur bur at
indochino.com that's 50 off a purchase
of 399 or more at ind o c h i n o dot
com promo code burr
all right that is what
i'm conversing about is there anything
else i wanted to talk about
before i get into the whole thing
um oh i know what i that that movie fat
city that i watched
you know they have one of their fights
in the stockton auditorium which still
exists
50 years later and it was like
let's see it was almost 50 years oh my
god it's almost 100 years old i think it
was made in 2024
um
that'd be a cool place to play
i don't think i've ever been to stockton
um
with all the rich people getting pushed
out by even richer people
in uh san francisco
and then them spilling into oakland i
would think people that are in oakland
would then get squirted out
to stockton
who knows
who the hell knows uh
all right
and with that i'm gonna a little bit of
a grumpy move because i think i [ __ ]
up my shoulder yet again
the ongoing things me cutting down on
cigars and trying to get my shoulders in
shape whatever
and my temper
and
sunscreen
all these losing battles all right re
losing a finger oh this is this guy last
week he tried to pick up a baby tiger
shark that thing [ __ ] rolled over on
him and just bit his finger off and he
he acted like
he just goes i just lost my god damn
pinky finger
i would be like
i would have been freaking out i'm
[ __ ] deformed
uh hey billy bath's up
salts on monday morning's podcast you
mentioned that losing a pinky finger is
probably for the best
um i was saying out of all the fingers
you could lose i don't know are you
really going to give me [ __ ] here i was
saying you can't throw a change up i did
say that
my procrastination need for useless
information was peaked turns out the
pinky finger does a disproportionate
amount of gripping
uh
while all the other human beings
human beings other fingers are its
helpers
basically the reason human beings have
opposit opposables thumbs
the springboard of our evolution from
being just another ape
apes have thumbs don't they
i thought it was because we ate
mushrooms there's so many [ __ ]
internet theories is that the thing is
that the thing is doing the opposite
opposing is the little finger yeah well
guess what the ring finger is going to
step up on his hand
the reason why the ring finger isn't
doing [ __ ] is because the pinky's there
all right the pinky just went down the
ring fingers coming in off the bench
it doesn't have a choice it's got to get
it done
i say the guy's ring finger will become
stronger than yours and mine put
together anyway so if you have your
little finger amputated you're going to
lose a significant amount of grip
strength when holding everyday small
objects initially
initially you will
uh given the choice that's yeah it's
like your other sense is heightened same
thing with the ring finger the ring
finger steps up
steps up puts down the clipboard and now
you can do a pull up given the choice
you want
to give up the index finger on the hand
you don't use for writing as the other
two
of the middle digits will take over its
job who knew thanks for the podcast and
the comedy it keeps us grounded in these
mercurial times all right just out of
curiosity like did you just google one
thing like you the fact that you had no
idea and now you're like talking to me
like you're an authority
um and i'm defensive because i was
saying i don't think the pinkie's that
big a deal
i think it's like the best one to lose
as far as like you know if you're
walking around in public like no one's
really gonna notice that
you know if your hands sort of like
[ __ ] relax i don't think that they
notice it
did that just pique your interest and
now you're gonna [ __ ] slam that down
listen man i'm just trying to fill up an
hour every week i don't need you coming
in here cross-examining me
um i'm kidding i'm kidding that's
actually was interesting but i would
think that the pinky finger would i mean
the ring finger would then do something
i could only feel like i'm right now
like i would do something it's not just
gonna sit there
um if you're ever inclined to do a show
like you ever see like uh people with no
arms working as bank tellers how
flexible their [ __ ] legs are do you
think that they would be there and then
doing all this [ __ ] with their feet i
can't [ __ ] do that their feet are
acting like hands why because they have
no arms
hence they got no nothing to put their
hands on
that's what i'm saying that's that's my
that's my rebuttal
your your thing that got peaked just got
peaked by my peak twin peaks um if
you're ever inclined to do a show in
bangkok
uh know that there's a huge expat
community of stand-up lovers who will
support the [ __ ] out of it we sold out
chappelle and jeffrey's within a week
of tickets released just saying why i
want the locals to go
you know i don't want to go all the way
to bangkok and talk to some guy from
houston texas or [ __ ]
you know the valley i can do that out
here
wait a second now my interest has been
peaked
um
my interest has been peaked
what because i made a statement you had
to [ __ ] prove me wrong in front of
all my listeners huh take me down a peg
is that what you wanted to do well i
hope you feel better because you did
um
[ __ ]
capital of thailand
x
pats
how many
what do we got
bangkok ranks 20th on a list
of expat friendly cities oh is this
where all the [ __ ] pedophiles go
they get in trouble and then they just
[ __ ] screw when they go over there or
is that bali i don't know we'll find out
all right well thank you for the
information
so
i was trying to look for a [ __ ]
bright side of seeing some guy get his
pinky bit off
uh now he can't hold his rod or reel
uh
re-cakes
oh my idea for cakes you know because
they have hooters
you make you make a restaurant called
cakes they serve the same shitty chicken
wings except the girls have uh nice
asses
as opposed to uh big titties you know
just fill in a void
and then when that works you make uh
feedies
um dear billy brainstorm i think cakes
is a good idea for a counter play to
hooters i just like to add that size of
either tits or ass is overrated
it's all about shape i've heard an
evolutionary biologist speak
on this as well when asked about the
attraction to large tits or ass
what
where the [ __ ] were you that you were
watching an evolutionary biologist speak
and somebody was just like that's very
interesting how we we went from being
apes to now driving teslas that are
going to drive it for us
um
as fascinating as the evolution of man
is can we talk tits and ass please and
the person was just why
anyway he didn't use the terms tits and
ass right he was much more eloquent and
respectful i dated two girls with large
tits one was a long time ago when she
laid down they almost disappeared one of
them is my current wife and she's 39 and
they're still perky and whatnot she
works out
and has a great ass a great ass too i
dated a girl who bragged about her ass
but it was just big and there was
nothing special about it the size wars
are a young man's dead end game shape is
what matters i don't need a giant ass if
it looks like
a bag of old yogurt
hey man i was just trying to [ __ ]
open a restaurant and you're sitting
there like like the chicks i'm gonna
have work in there won't have like i
don't know what a [ __ ] nice ass looks
like i need to talk to an evolutionary
biologist what the [ __ ] is in the water
this week you guys are all coming at me
anyways this guy's going on and on about
himself and i don't need giant tits
if they're just fat because the girl is
fat ps if you open cakes you better make
routine visits to locations wearing a
robe and smoking a cigar while brazenly
pinching employees asses
uh no if i'm in the restaurant community
as a ginger one of us already [ __ ] up
that world so i can they had me
i'd have to do a [ __ ] 23andme to
prove that i wasn't mario batali you
know i still have his cookware and i
still stand by multi mario
it's a [ __ ] great cooking show uh
celebrities at your shows
hey billy billy espresso bean burr
uh my wife and i went to one of your
your spots last wednesday
when you [ __ ] murdered kid
we noticed gene simmons was in the
audience two-part question did they tell
you he's there before you went up and
does it affect you in any way knowing
that a celebrity
is in the audience before you perform
uh no they didn't and no it doesn't it
used to
when i was younger
because then you want to see if you're
making them laugh because you feel like
they're famous they must know something
and if i make them laugh then i must
know what they know
um
did that just shut off my [ __ ]
okay
i don't know if you got that this some
phone just rang uh yeah i used to focus
i remember seeing william shatner came
to the comedy cellar
and i was all like looking at him to see
if i made him laugh
you know and i can't even remember if i
did or not but like uh
no they didn't tell me that he was there
actually i i
i didn't know that he was there
um thank you very much for the last my
wife has officially called you her
spirit animal and we can't wait for your
movie to come out oh thank you
um
i think uh
if it was um
i don't know
i think then it was it was comedians
comedians that i wanted to have a good
set in front of i remember a long time
ago uh
when i was doing
the rich [ __ ] tour with don l ashy
larry rawlings
and uh
uh the late great charlie murphy i
remember we went down and we did uh
the comedy union
and uh eddie murphy came out
to see us and i was definitely aware
that he was there and of course i did
not have a good set
uh that was way back in 2004 and i was
[ __ ]
i was not happy with myself i didn't
even go up and say hello to him because
i was like i'm not saying hello after
that [ __ ] set
um and looking back it probably wasn't
as bad as i thought it was and i ended
up meeting him one time at this netflix
thing and he was like the [ __ ] nicest
guy ever
um
really cool guy so i should have said
hello so i don't know anyway whacked out
news um hey billy buffoon
did you hear about this elon musk [ __ ]
this week
wall street journal reports he had an
affair with the wife of the head of
google uh turns out they can both prove
they've never been alone in the same
place
the article also said he's not friends
with the guy from google anymore turns
out they are the wall street journal
even admitted that they didn't reach out
to any of the parties involved
shouldn't he sue the ink off these [ __ ]
um yeah back in the day that would you
would get the [ __ ] suit out of you
because
newspapers
are still held for libel and slander and
that type of [ __ ] but i just think
because of the internet
that you can just say anything that you
want about anybody and nobody's liable
for anything uh
that i don't think it even matters what
anybody says about you anymore
anyways he says it doesn't affect me in
my simple life but collectively it's
[ __ ] up the world everyone starts
talking about this stuff while
as you would say they're poisoning the
food supply
um
oh yeah yeah they turned our food supply
into poison when um
check out that new havens farms
i think that's what it's called on um
instagram i follow that account it's
really inspiring me to get something
going some sort of garden or something
and what little yard that i have uh
if someone printed a story like that
about you would you take legal action
i'm not talking an entertainment rag i'm
talking a legit news source
now
because it's out there people are
already gonna believe what they're gonna
believe and then
it's like
if you
sue them
then you're just like prolonging the
story
and then it just stays out there longer
and longer and then you actually become
part of the reason why
the whole thing's going down the toilet
because rather than
talking about something important
like the level that people were watching
i mean i'm happy johnny depp won and
everything but the level that everybody
was watching that [ __ ] trial and
talking about it while all this other
[ __ ] is going on
um
and nobody paying attention like you
know trying to figure out why it's like
seven dollars a gallon and you're still
blaming colors of ties rather than the
fact that they [ __ ]
just
counterfeited 20 trillion dollars and
threw it into the country uh into the
economy and like how we're fighting a
never-ending [ __ ] war that bankrupted
this country i don't know how many times
and every august we just print more
[ __ ] money
you know with nothing behind it it just
causes inflation
and no one wants to look at that no
wants to look at the people who [ __ ]
did it people want to defend the people
that did it because they they wear the
color tie that they like it's the whole
[ __ ] thing is stupid and they all get
away with it so
i'm hoping against hope that eventually
people will rise above all of that dumb
[ __ ] and uh
not take the system down because it's
too big to do that i would just as
individuals just try to ignore it
and focus on yourself
grow your own food
uh i don't know what to do about the
money supply
but we all we all just somehow just
looked out for each other so then no
matter what gloom and doom thing that
they did
you'd be like yeah you know it's not
gonna happen it'll be fine
i don't think there's gonna be a giant
race war
because i've read enough books and i
have a nice wide variety of friends that
i know that what you're saying is
[ __ ] you know or you can choose to
have your head in the [ __ ] sand and
watch cnn and fox
and have them scare the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of you every goddamn day um while never
giving you a uh
you know never giving you any solutions
um
you know it's [ __ ] hilarious donald
trump's team is just emailing the [ __ ]
out of me
and i will not put him in trash because
his the subject lines are just [ __ ]
hilarious
here's one donald j trump it just says
unbelievable
and and i could be like i'm unbelievable
i am the greatest or can you believe
what sleepy joe just did i love that he
can call him sleepy joe because he's a
democrat and it's not making fun of
dementia
um
like donald trump can literally do
anything the guy [ __ ] made fun of uh
john mccain
a prisoner of war a war hero he called
him a loser who got caught and all of
these people america love it or leave
and support the troops didn't give a
[ __ ]
because he wore a red tie and was saying
what they wanted to hear
it's [ __ ] amazing this [ __ ] guy
is amazing now i know that there's
somebody on the liberal left i just
don't have them right now that i know is
doing the exact same thing that guy who
kept taking his dick out in new york
i don't know i don't know what party was
in i don't pay attention to it here's
another one team trump and it says and
you can have it
like i don't even know it's all
like we need to have something that
grabs the eye that makes them want to
open the thing
let me let's see here what else do i get
here congratulations
was another one i got from him
will you step up
um
read one more here
there was an
epic shirt
seen at something did you see what
happened
at my rally in alaska
i called some front row patriots onto my
rally stage because of the incredible
trump rally shirts they were wearing
after i saw this amazing shirt i knew i
had to have them ready to go for you for
patriots like you this guy's selling
merch
[Laughter]
did you see
what the three people in alaska were
wearing
that we paid them to wear so then we
brought it up on stage and act like it
was an improvised moment so we could
sell some t-shirts
um
anyway
i thought this just my one question
about that guy just what exactly
what business is this guy running
that he has time to to just
walk away from all of his businesses be
president
lose the election
okay rerun lose
and then never stop running
and start making like [ __ ]
hey some fans made a cool t-shirt about
the [ __ ] that i do we should
mass-produce this he sounds like a
[ __ ] podcaster
oh people we're in a rock and a hard
place we got this [ __ ] jerk off
coming back
to go up against the current president
who can't even ride a bicycle can't go
upstairs shouldn't drive a [ __ ] car
let alone give a speech i mean we got to
do better than this what i'm hoping is
biden doesn't win the nomination
when we get somebody like in their 40s
with their faculties
for the democrats and then the
republicans come with somebody in their
40s with their faculties
okay their faculties meaning both of
them are way more towards the middle
okay and we just sort of abandoned the
jesus freaks and the hairy-legged white
chicks
those lunatics all right the people two
in their fields
on both sides and we just kind of get
back to uh was everybody just [ __ ]
relax
everybody have a sandwich everybody calm
down
everything's gonna be all right even
though it isn't
um
all right sorry why am i talking
politics i don't know it's sort of
[ __ ] inevitable
it is what happens but as i mentioned uh
before
believe it or not
the los angeles dodgers
i mean can you imagine this little team
that could this 250 million dollar team
that could whatever they spent this year
it now has the best record in baseball
because the yankees went on a little bit
of a skit here let's let's let's check
out
let's check out the standings if i can i
think the red sox are in last place
the only only thing good about that is
we do have a tough uh
we do have a tough division
so we're only a couple games under 500
and we're already in the last place
um teams
all right here we go
what are they just trying to sell me
merch here
scores schedules stats standings
all right let's look in because this is
where a lot of casual fans tap out
the yankees with a commanding
uh
what do they have they have like a they
have a 12 game lead over toronto
three games behind toronto
it's the tampa bay
lightning
tampa bay double rays tampa bay rays
then the baltimore orioles at 51 and 51
or a half a game ahead of the boston red
sox um
incredible toronto went eight and two
the last ten yankees went five and five
so toronto picked up three games
they picked up three games on them we'll
see what happens and then the rest of
the houston's good this year
hang on buddy i'm doing i'm wrapping up
the podcast
um
nobody in the al central seems to be
doing anything
houston's got a
67 and 36 jesus christ
they'd only be two games behind the
yankees this is not a foregone
conclusion the mets they are the mets
though
atlanta has a decent record
dodgers best record
best record in the friggin league
all right let's let's look at team
leaders here shall we we're gonna do a
little baseball here
what do we got here
stats stats and more stats
dude they were showing like reverse web
gems on uh espn and i swear to god out
of like the 15 bloopers they showed like
three of them were the red sox
just our guys losing fly balls like how
many more times they gonna show that
inside the park [ __ ] home run
the blue jay guy head
um
all right let's see here what is this
here
regular season
is this batting average
i swear to god how [ __ ] difficult can
you make a goddamn website hitting okay
select a player that's not what i want
to do i don't want to select a player i
want to see leaders
regular season
all-star game no okay regular season
year to date standard expanded
select a player pool
all players qualified select a split
home and way i just want to see who's
got the best [ __ ] batting average oh
this is on base percentage all right so
who's got the best average who's leading
the league in [ __ ] home runs
all right
justin verlander lowest era in the
american league we're getting somewhere
now
all right
miami marlins sandy alcantra cantara
dylan cease
shane
what the [ __ ] are all the yankees i
thought they had a bun oh there is
nestor cortez
i don't like the yankees but i like that
guy
i like that guy um
well that's in the whole league all
right
how about some [ __ ] home runs here
all right i give up with this [ __ ] mlb
league
leaders
league leaders all right here we go
here we go
espn.com all right
333 batting average
louis
oh my god
a raise
a-r-r-a-e-z
i'm too white to pronounce that properly
my my
apologies uh
major league wins by pitcher justin
verlander houston now how the [ __ ] are
the yankees not in there with all of
those goddamn wins
because they're spreading it around
um
all right home runs is aaron judge 40
[ __ ] two
42.
and those are those are legit
no steroids none of that [ __ ] i'm i i
buy that i 100 buy that that's [ __ ]
paul bunyan going up there
um
runs batted in aaron judge 91
and we got hits i love hits i'd like
that stat
freddy freeman
freddy freeman what a great name la
dodger's 128 hits
these these offensive numbers seem like
down other than uh what aaron judge is
doing
um
the pitching is just too [ __ ] good
now they're talking about maybe lowering
lowering the mound again
i mean it's already down to an a cup
what the [ __ ] are they gonna have out
there
uh stolen bases 28 when's the next ricky
henderson gonna come along
uh
quality starts
i don't even know what that stat is
strikeouts there you go garrett cole
new york yankees 162.
that's some that's a badass stat
just punching them out
good [ __ ]
um
i mean
it'd be better if i saw a [ __ ] red
sox somewhere in there but you know what
i'm hanging in there with them
that's what i'm doing um
so anyway people that is the podcast for
this week uh i'm gonna have the great
paul vergies out here we're gonna knock
out some of those anything betters i
just got so busy with the movie he got
busy promoting his special
and we live in the opposite side of the
country here so we're going to knock out
some of those this week
and
thank you to everybody that's been
watching my stand-up special live at red
rocks please tell your friends about it
i'm very proud of it
and i think that's it what do i have
coming up next my next gig is i'm doing
arthur ashe stadium
in um
in queens new york and i was so tempted
to go out and get a wig and a headband
and go out as 1970s john mcenroe
if i didn't need my beard for something
i just feel it's going to look stupid if
i do it and i got the beard
this is what i was going to do
i can't say what i was going to do
because i might still do it
uh i'm not doing it i'm not dressing up
but i'm still going to i might do a
little johnny macdonald
i'll tell you about it later
oh what a silly job i have um
okay that's all these vista light drums
i kind of like that they track you
you know
look at this i mean i'm on espn's
website and then i get sponsored
headline ludwig vista light fab three
piece shell pack green
and then they got one black sparkle
smoke and black
wait that's still available that's not
gonna be the 24 is it
it's gonna be the 22.
oh this is one of these things i'm going
to click on this and they're going to
say like it's not available
that was the 50-year anniversary one
what sizes are these what sizes are
these the shell pack
yeah it's a 22. hey go [ __ ] yourself are
you i'm not i'm not buying that [ __ ] all
right i'm babbling here all right that's
the podcast everybody
uh
i'm gonna go play with my kids all right
thank you to everybody that came out in
montreal have a great couple of days and
go [ __ ] yourself
you